- Well, hi, everybody.
Welcome to WPS208.
This is Covered California with AWS
and today we're gonna talk a little bit
about the data-driven
customer retention strategies
that Covered California has put in place
to help with customer retention.
Well, let me go ahead and go forward here.
I'm Chris Carter.
I am a senior sales specialist with AWS.
I focus on Amazon Connect
for public sector accounts in the West,
and I'm joined today by Glenn and Kevin.
Would you like to introduce yourselves?
- Good afternoon. I'm Kevin Cornish.
I'm the chief information
officer at Covered California.
I run our technology
that supports our mission
that we're gonna talk
about this afternoon.
- And hi, everyone. I'm Glenn Oyoung.
I'm the chief marketing
officer at Covered California.
You could probably tell
because I'm the one that took the selfie.
I wanna remember this.
How many times do you
get to talk to people
with a bunch of yellow headsets?
Thank you for joining us.
(Chris laughs)
- Excellent.
Okay, so real briefly, Glenn
will do a quick introduction
to Covered California.
So for those that aren't
familiar with Covered California,
you'll learn a little
bit about who they are.
Some of the market forces and changes
that have happened recently
that are driving, I guess, concern maybe
amongst the residents and constituents
of the state of California
in obtaining health insurance.
Some different initiatives that
Covered California has taken
to drive better retention
or improve retention for their customers
and marketing outreach.
And then we'll wrap it up with Q&A.
Q&A is not gonna be live today,
so when we're done with the session,
you can just meet us, like, up
in the front or in the back,
and we can take live Q&A when we're done.
So with that, I'm gonna
hand it over to Glenn.
- Thanks so much, Chris.
- Yeah.
- Hi again.
And thank you so much for
taking time out of your day
to come learn a little bit
about Covered California,
what we do, and retention,
and ultimately how our technology partners
help us facilitate that.
So before we get into it,
if you're not familiar
with Covered California,
we are the state healthcare exchange
for the state of California.
Here on the slide,
you can see many of the plans
that we connect people to.
But we're not just Expedia
connecting people to plans.
We do much more than that.
But I just wanna level set.
And many states do have
healthcare exchanges,
and for those that don't,
they direct their folks to healthcare.gov.
What is our mission?
Our mission, as you can
see, is really fourfold.
And so as I just alluded to,
we do connect people to plans.
That's core to our mission.
We want people to get covered.
That's in our name.
I paused like I just realized
that, but I've known that.
You know, and what does that really mean?
So it's our job, it's our mission
to give people affordable choices,
that those choices are
not just affordable,
but the plans and the coverage
that we connect people to
are high quality.
We care very deeply about health equity
and what that means is
closing the health equity gaps
that do exist in our country
and just really around the world.
And we have the great ability
to work with these plans
and work with the plans that we select
and work with every day
to try and make sure
that we're closing gaps
for the communities that we serve.
And speaking of service across the board,
whether it's marketing or IT
or our service center, you name it,
every part of Covered California,
we are committed to the mission,
truly and deeply ingrained in our hearts,
and that shows up in exceptional service.
I do want to pause and say
a quick story if I could,
which is on the very first
day of open enrollment,
at about 1:00 a.m.,
Kevin and I got a text from one
of our partners here, Brian,
who's, you can wave, it's okay,
silently wave,
telling us about the very first enrollment
in the state of California.
And, you know, emojis were shared.
And I say that to say that I know
that everyone on the stage and
the teams that we work with,
including the partners that
we choose to work with,
we choose to work with people
like Brian and his team
because that mission is paramount to us.
And I hear we have an hour,
so I'm gonna tell you another story
and it's gonna get a little more personal,
but I want you to think
about what that means
in the state of California.
My parents are immigrants.
They came to this country with nothing
in pursuit of the American dream.
My father was an engineer
and I think he would be very proud
that I get to stand in
front of STEM people
who are much smarter than
me in the realm of STEM
and talk about our mission.
My father unfortunately
passed away of cancer.
He worked his way up to be an engineer,
a successful engineer.
He could have picked any plan
he wanted when he retired.
He did not pick any of
the plans I showed you.
He picked a plan where most of
the providers speak Mandarin,
is a smaller plan,
and, ultimately, one of
the great traumatic things
in my life
is battling with his providers
and battling with his plan
and battling with anyone I could talk to
to make the last few weeks
of his life more comfortable.
So health equity is something I say a lot,
but for me personally,
that's what I think about when
I think about health equity.
I do think about my dad,
I do think about myself,
but I think about the people
unlike my dad or myself
who don't speak English,
didn't go to college,
didn't have a PhD,
don't have a son that can
even try to do that battle.
That is the complexity
of our healthcare system.
And I share that
because oftentimes, we
talk about these things.
Complexity, affordability, equity.
For me, it's very personal.
And I know that everyone
at Covered California
has some version of this story
that propels us to work as hard as we do.
So thank you for letting
me share that with you
because it's not about me or my dad,
it's about Californians,
it's about the people we serve.
That's what makes us work super hard
to try and do whatever
it is that we can do
to help our fellow Californians.
And I can tell you from talking
to people in other states
and state healthcare exchanges,
the feeling is very pervasive.
That's what we mean by our mission.
We've been really good at what we do.
One in six Californians have
or will have been a
Covered California member
in their lifetime,
whether they ever thought
they would be or not, right?
And one in three,
if you add in our partners at Medi-Cal,
have been served by Medi-Cal
or Covered California.
That's huge. Just think about that.
I will say that there are people
in this convention right now
who do not think they will
ever need Covered California,
but one in six of them might.
And it's our job to make sure,
especially in that type of environment
that they think, "I'll never need that,
so I don't really need to
connect with that brand,"
it's my job in marketing
and many of our peers
to make sure that, I hope that's true,
I hope you always have an
employee-sponsored insurance,
but if you don't, if you're laid off,
I hope the first thing you think about
is Covered California, right?
That's the job.
And we have been very successful
in reducing our uninsured
rate from 17% to 6%.
Meaning 94% of eligible Californians
prior to this moment in time
have found insurance
either through Covered
California or Medi-Cal
or their employer, right?
Last year I think we set a record
for almost two million enrolled,
which is very, very, we're proud of that.
And at the same time, this
year's a different year.
And so what do I mean by that?
Our government was shut
down, and I'll get into that,
but if you're tracking,
then you know that the subsidies
are planning to expire.
There's a lot of federal policy changes
and broader landscape changes
in healthcare in general
that have nothing to do with
decisions that we've made,
but make it even more complex
and more scary for Californians.
And so our answer to that,
starting from a year ago,
was really doubling down
on telling the story of
who we are from upper,
I'm a marketer, so go with me,
but upper funnel, right?
You guys know, building
awareness, building trust,
and working with partners
like Kevin and his team
and many of you in the front row
to take that trust and awareness
and turn that into action.
That's where technology
really comes into play.
And so I wanna show you a bit
before we get too deep
into the technology aspect
our new brand platform,
which is for the love of Californians.
And this is our
declaration, our first spot,
which is called Declaration
because it is indeed a declaration
of what our intent is here
at Covered California.
(bright music)
- [Announcer] We love California.
But we love Californians even more.
60 countries in one state
and the music of 200 languages.
At Covered California,
we believe every single Californian
deserves healthcare that works.
So let us haggle.
Let us cut through the confusion.
We are not a health insurance company.
We're in it for you, because we are you.
For the love of Californians.
Covered California.
- In other places I do this, people clap,
but I know we can't.
So just if you liked it, give me a sign.
Oh, you can clap.
Okay, we'll break some rules.
Thank you.
I wasn't asking for applause.
I just wanted you to know if it was done.
But, again, joking aside,
our brand platform,
our creative campaign, our tagline,
which you will see for many, many years,
I hope for many, maybe
even a decade, I hope,
is for the love of California, right?
That is gonna permeate everything we do
from an outreach perspective.
And it's great because although it's new,
it's not really new.
We have always loved Californians
and we're just saying it out loud
so people understand who we are
and why we do what we do.
So as we think about that,
we want to start showing you
beyond the big brand and the pivot
what does that love, how does
that show up in this moment
where we have to focus
on some other aspects
that we typically haven't
had to focus on before?
- Thank you, Glenn.
I'll clap for you.
- Oh, thank you. I'll clap for you.
- So at Covered California,
we're obsessed by three things.
The first is our mission.
Glenn talked a little
bit about our mission.
It's to make sure that
every California resident,
every resident of the great
state of California has access
to affordable, high-quality healthcare.
He talked about some numbers.
When Covered California came
online about a dozen years ago,
more than 17% of our state's population
had no access to insurance.
That means when their
kid got the sniffles,
they ran to the ER, right?
That means that they were using
very expensive healthcare options
in pretty inconvenient ways.
And they were putting themselves
and their families at risk
for immense financial catastrophes, right?
Any health scare
could take their car off
the road, essentially,
their family's car off the road.
So that number one is
affinity for our mission.
Number two, our number two obsession
is consumers' experience.
And so we're a state agency.
We're an agency of the
state of California, right?
When I came to Covered California,
I was a little bit
intrigued by people saying
that the consumer experience
is our North Star.
It's something we're really,
really obsessive about.
I'm like, "The government
doesn't care about me.
They care about me when
they want my taxes, right?
They care about me when I
have to pay a traffic ticket.
But otherwise they don't
care about me too much."
Covered California really cares
about our consumers and our citizens.
And so that's that customer obsession.
We're gonna talk a little bit
about the consumer journey
and how some of the technology
we've deployed recently
has really improved that consumer journey
and the customer's experience.
We'll talk a little bit about friction,
which is the enemy of a
consumer's experience,
and what we do to reduce friction.
The third thing we're obsessed with
is information security and privacy.
Glenn talked about one in six Californians
have been through Covered California.
We are also the front door,
our platform CalHEERS is the front door
for eligibility determination
for the Medicaid system in California,
which is called Medi-Cal.
So every year, about 17 million
members of our population,
you know, that's close to half,
39 million people in California,
come through our system and
either go to a Medi-Cal solution
or come to Covered California.
That means over time we've collected PII
and some other forms of health information
on nearly 25 million Californians.
So we're obsessed about
information privacy and security.
We want to safeguard
those consumers' data.
So I'm gonna talk a little
bit about a challenge
that we faced in the last couple years
that we recognized in
that consumer journey.
Remember, for the consumer
journey, friction is a bad thing.
We don't want it.
We want to push people through a workflow
that gets them to a conclusion,
which is they're enrolled
in a health plan,
as easy and smoothly
and quickly as possible.
So we found that the way
we were doing eligibility determination
on this platform called CalHEERS
was giving anxiety to about
33% of our population.
They were literally exiting
the workflow at that point.
We did a little bit of digging
and started to determine
that this eligibility
determination process we used,
which was relying on credit checking,
was not something that our
demographic liked, right?
A large number of 'em don't
have great credit scores
or maybe even credit scores at all.
Also, a large number of
'em just don't wanna share
that kind of information
with the government
or even have that conversation, right?
And so we found that a
third of our consumers
would exit the workflow.
They would come to our solution,
our self-serve platform.
They would do an eligibility determination
and determine they were eligible
for some form of subsidy,
which would reduce the cost
of that insurance plan.
They would begin to do
some what we call shopping
and comparing health plan options
between some of the health plans
that you saw on the slide
that Glenn showed before.
And then when it came
time for us to determine
you are really who you say you are
so we know that that eligibility
determination is valid,
we would go to this credit check process
and they'd say, "Ugh, I want outta here.
I don't like this. I'm uncomfortable.
I leave."
And for the most part, we never
saw those consumers again.
So a third of our population was leaving
before we scored a goal, right?
We were not able to satisfy
our mission with them.
So we began to look in the
marketplace for a solution.
And we've been on the Amazon
cloud for about four years.
We've had a great journey
from an on-prem solution
when I joined the company five years ago
to a highly-tuned
microservices-based, cloud-native,
taking advantage of cloud platform.
And so we initially started to look at,
well, what other solutions are out there
that would plug into this AWS ecosystem?
And how could we take advantage of someone
who we would trust because
they're in our system?
Remember that third obsession
with privacy and security
that we really need to make sure
that this was, you know,
very sensitive information
and a sensitive workflow.
Who could do that?
So we found a solution from Socure,
which does not use the concept
of a credit-based risk score,
and we began to prototype it.
It solved two problems for us.
One was what I talked about,
that exit ramp where 33% of
our clients were just leaving
and never coming back.
The other one was there's
a lot of focus lately,
both inside our industry and
from the federal government,
on fraud, waste, and abuse.
And so we were also looking for a solution
that would solve some of the potential
fraud, waste, and abuse issues
that we may have been
experiencing in our system
and maybe not even known about it.
So we picked Socure and we did a deploy.
Talk a little bit about some
of the things that this did.
So a very different approach
to validating consumers.
The long story short
here is we were able to,
I'm just gonna jump to the next screen
'cause I like the stats here,
we were able to,
on the left side, from
a consumer experience,
we moved to a seamless
deploy in our system.
Worked with our solution,
again, called CalHEERS.
No noticeable difference
for the consumers.
We had some very effective
fraud deterrence components of this.
So some of the statistics
you'll see up on the right,
we initially, right off the bat,
found about 5% of the transactions
that were coming into the
system were fraudulent
and the system was able to
identify those consumers
and take them out of the workflow.
We also did, the next
thing was the passive flow
of consumers through our solution.
We are today operating
about 85% of our consumers
passively go through,
meaning they don't have to do anything.
We know enough about their biometrics,
about their background
and information from
the Socure secret sauce
that we are validating them
without any more action on their behalf.
About 15% of our
consumers don't pass that.
And we go to another form of validation
and Chris will talk,
he'll walk us through a little
bit of that in a moment.
But essentially in the end,
98% of the consumers are getting through
this really critical step.
We're being able to
validate their identity.
We're limiting the fraudsters,
that roughly 5% of the
folks who are coming in
trying to do something that was not right.
And if you recall,
that problem we had
initially that got us here,
33% of our consumers leaving
and never coming back,
never getting to an insurance plan,
that's gone.
We are passing 98% of them through.
They're down the highway.
They're going through the
shop and compare step.
They're finding one of those health plans
that is affordable for their family.
They're making sure they're
getting the maximum subsidy,
which is reducing the cost
of that plan for them.
And they're signing up
for health insurance.
And that's really important to us, right?
We are still concerned
that 6% of Californians
who probably have access
to a solution through us
are not taking advantage of it.
So this is a way of getting us
back focused on that consumer experience.
How do we make sure that we
get more Californians insured
that we get to that basic human right,
which is I have a human
right to be healthy.
I have a human right
to access this amazing healthcare system
in the United States
and not be worried about
some catastrophic impact
on my family's finances.
It's really, really important to us,
going back to our first
obsession, which is our mission.
So I think I'm gonna give it to Chris.
Chris is gonna talk a
little bit about that step
where the passive verification
doesn't work, right?
The 15% that have to go to some next step.
He's gonna walk us through how that works.
- Great. Thank you, Kevin.
All right, so as Kevin mentioned,
about 84% of the people
that go through the system
will go through what's
called passive verification.
And with passive verification,
the users will input,
you know, personally
identifiable information.
So, name, address, other information.
And through a process
that Socure provides,
they'll do device analytics
and a number of other things
and basically process all of
that information passively
to make a determination of
that person's identity or not.
And again, 84% of the people
will pass through that
not knowing that they've ever even
gone through this process.
So it's great right off the bat.
But for the 16% that don't
make it through that process,
then they go to what's called
DocV or document verification.
And Socure provides this mobile platform
or this type of experience
where you can provide a
government-issued ID and biometrics,
in this case, a picture,
and Socure will use that
to basically provide a
additional mechanism now
to validate that that person
is who they say they are.
So with, like, the
photo that you see here,
it's comparing that photo and liveliness,
you know, things like make
sure your eyes are open
or look to the left, look to the right.
They're even checking things
like is their shoulder up?
You know, 'cause your shoulder would be up
if you're holding a phone in
front of you to take a picture.
Like, little things like that.
So it's checking, you know, liveliness,
it's checking your document
and using AWS services,
which I'll talk about on the next slide,
but to extract all of the information
off of those documents
and compare that to
the passive information
that was collected previously.
And again, as Kevin mentioned,
the vast, vast majority of
people between these two methods
are now able to get through this process
and not fall out of the
system like they were before.
A little bit of an eye chart,
but this is kind of what
it looks like in practice.
Off to the right-hand side of
the slide are the AWS services
that Socure is using.
It's a advanced machine learning model.
A lot of proprietary stuff
that they're using behind the scenes
to provide their service.
But some of the services from AWS
that they're using to
form the basis of that
are Amazon Textract.
Textract is the service that is used
to pull the information
off of the documents,
so pull texts off of the IDs
or off other documents that
could be basically scanned.
They're using Amazon Rekognition
for the photo recognition part
and the liveliness detection.
So again, you can say things like,
"Turn your head to the right
or turn your head to the left
and open your mouth."
Like, you can do things like that
to detect that you're actually
looking at a live person
and not a picture of a person
that might be on an ID.
They're using services like SageMaker
to help develop their ML models.
Again, it's their service
that they're providing,
but they're able to build
quickly using SageMaker
and, you know, adapt and
continue to develop the service
and make improvements.
Amazon Pinpoint for messaging.
So their SMS and email,
this is moving to end user messaging.
So if you haven't heard,
Amazon Pinpoint is moving
toward end user messaging.
They're moving to that as well.
But the basis of Socure is
based on Amazon Pinpoint.
And then as Kevin mentioned before,
all of this is basically co-located
in the same region within AWS
as the CalHEERS app itself.
So it's a very low latency, secure,
and allows access or
allows the two systems
to interact together
in I guess a very efficient manner
and secure manner.
So with that, we'll move on
to case study number two.
- I think that's me.
- Yep, Glenn.
- All right. Thanks so much.
Great. So thanks again.
We're gonna now turn our attention
to our second case study.
And you've heard me mention retention.
That's not necessarily something
that we've ever been
really focused on that much
at Covered California.
It's always been a part,
and I think if you were to step back
and say each division, each department
is doing something retention related,
but really if you think
about Covered California
and state healthcare exchanges,
we are a transitory experience
for most of our members.
Meaning our average
tenure's 14 months, right?
Prior to Covered California,
I worked for one of those health plans.
The average tenure ideally
is as long as humanly possible, right?
So for us, we're meant to
be here in a moment in time
for most people where they need us.
And then again, ideally, in this country,
the ideal path forward is
employee-sponsored healthcare.
You get it from Deloitte,
you get it from Amazon,
you get it from your employer,
or you start your own business
or something like that.
So we haven't really had to focus on that.
That wasn't really core, right?
But we do need to focus on that very much
for all the reasons that
I'm about to get into.
And so that created
another level of urgency
for us across the organization
to really think about,
what is our approach
and strategy to retention?
Why does it matter?
It matters because we don't want people
to go uninsured, right?
And then how does technology
and how does working together
help us achieve that?
So I've mentioned a couple headwinds.
I'm just gonna lightly touch on it.
But it's clear from our focus groups,
it's clear from whether you talk
about federal, state,
city, it doesn't matter.
I'm in the trust business,
we're in the trust business.
If you don't trust Covered California,
if you read the news
and it makes you want
to close down your app,
it's very hard for us to
talk to you about healthcare
or really anything.
And we see that in not only our research,
but very widely published research.
And it's been that way
before even this year, right?
This healthcare system in general,
because of the complexity,
because of surprise bills,
because of access problems
even dating back to the pandemic,
trust has really been a struggle
for everyone in this space.
And then specific to Covered California,
we've typically enjoyed
very high brand awareness,
but when you double-click
into beyond have you heard
of Covered California,
what do you know about Covered California,
what do you feel about Covered California,
the trend has been going down,
and again, that's even
before what's happening now
with our government's sort of stalemate
around federal tax subsidies.
So as a marketer, this is job security.
No, I'm just kidding.
As a marketer, this is the call to action.
And this is the need,
the urgent need for us to do something
to make sure that people take the time
to take notice of who we are
so that we then have the
right to pull alongside them
and tell them all the ways that
we can support them, right?
And so I've mentioned this a couple times,
but, you know, without
getting super jargony,
there are tax subsidies,
federal subsidies,
that are set to expire
at the end of this year
and the end of this year
is quickly approaching.
And even today,
depending on what day you
open up your news apps,
are they gonna get extended?
Are they not gonna get extended?
Are they extended for two years?
Should we even have the ACA?
This is the confusion that
I'm talking about, right?
And the end result in human context
is it creates a wave of emotions
that ultimately, for consumers, means
that many of them will
delay any kind of action
and many of them will
say, "It's too confusing,
I'm just gonna wait this out."
And again, the danger will be
that that 6% unemployed skyrockets
and our own internal
projections, you know, say
that potentially if
these subsidies expire,
something like a third of our members
will unfortunately make that
tough choice to not renew.
And it wouldn't be because
they don't know the value.
It wouldn't be because
they haven't had access
to high-quality, affordable plans.
For many of them,
it comes down to their health
insurance bills doubling
and having to make the choice
between paying for food,
literally, I'll say it again,
paying for food, paying
for gas to get to work,
paying for rent,
or this idea of healthcare insurance.
And something that I believe
after many years of marketing
is most humans are bad at managing risk.
Look at my haircut.
That's a great example.
Don't look from the back, right?
So when you layer that
on with this complexity,
again, that goes to this moment in time
where all of us at Covered California
really have to meet this moment.
I summarized the headwinds.
I would just say that
we did 21 focus groups
across the state.
So this is not just an opinion.
This is hearing from real people
who really are struggling
with this moment.
And healthcare is just one
part of their lives, right?
I mentioned the other areas
that we all have seen the
effects of inflation and so on.
And so really, again, the strategic shift
to a focus on retention
was really paramount.
And luckily for us as a team,
we've been thinking about
this for at least a year
and we've been working as a team
before this month for a year
to figure out what we can do
and then, again, stand up some things
to lean in and help.
And so what are those things, right?
Ultimately, I would just point
your attention to the bottom,
through all the wonders of
technology and our partnerships
and our wonderful team,
many of whom are sitting right here,
we are mining our own data
to ultimately understand our customers
and to profile the risk of leaving, right?
So a retention model, a risk profiling,
that then feeds into segmentation
and then, on the left, creates
more personalized messages,
more personalized, more nuanced messages.
And I'm smiling because
with my own marketing team,
I think we all know,
I will say, "Well, what do we
expect from Amazon," right?
Not AWS, but Amazon, right?
And what is that customer
experience expectation
that we have in for-profit brands,
in buying a car, in buying shoes,
in buying an airplane ticket?
Those are the same fluid expectations
that transfer to us, right?
It shouldn't be this hard.
People do expect us to know them
and to manifest that knowledge
into personalized outreach,
which we historically haven't done
as much as we could have, but we are now.
And then how does that show up
when you're talking to our agents
and how prepared are our
agents to also treat you
in a way that's more
tailored to your situation?
This is really the unlock
that this work with technology
and with AWS and our
partners have done for us.
I'm gonna hand it over to do
the triple-click into that.
- Yeah. Thank you, Glenn.
- Thanks.
- All right, so how does that work, right?
Or what does that look like,
these personalized messages,
and how do you develop those?
So the team at Deloitte,
along with Covered California,
started working backwards
from previous data,
from previous enrollees.
They built what's considered
or we'll call it a risk score.
And a risk score is really
just the modeled probability
that a member is going to renew or not,
and a number of factors
go into that risk score.
Things like a premium increase
or the way that they earn
income, you know, today.
Like, do they have a large salary
or are they a gig worker?
Their age.
You know, like, are they a young
person, maybe very healthy,
or are they older?
Are they taking care of dependents
or are they just taking
care of themselves?
So there's a lot of
factors that go into this.
And when you look at past data,
you can see how premium increases
might have impacted
certain audience segments
and you can make predictions
in the future then
about how these changes that
Glenn outlined a second ago
might impact the members in 2026.
So using R on Snowflake,
the Deloitte team modeled at scale
across hundreds of thousands,
millions even really, people
to develop risk scores and
created audience segments.
And I'm just gonna scroll
down here a little bit
in my notes.
So one example of an audience segment
is, let's say, a young
adult, age 26 to 35.
They live in a urban California city.
They're like a gig worker
or an hourly worker,
and their primary concern
is going to be the cost of insurance.
A 10 to $20 increase in monthly,
whoops, I don't know
what just happened there,
a 10 to $20 month increase,
a 10 to $20 per month increase
would really impact them.
And so they're primarily concerned
about what that cost is.
Another person, I don't
know what happened there,
I'll just go back on here.
Okay (chuckles).
Another audience segment
might be an older couple,
let's say 45 to 55, supporting dependents.
They might have maybe chronic
health issues in the family.
They're obviously going to be concerned
about price increases,
but for them, the most important thing
is to have continued insurance, right?
That's the most important thing.
I think all of us in here have realized,
you know, that you don't
really care about your health
until it goes bad.
You wake up one day and your back's out
and all of a sudden health matters, right?
They're already experiencing that.
So health insurance is
very important to them.
So with this, the team developed
these five audience segments
initially based primarily
on what the impact of
premium increases will have
on each of these different
audience segments
that were modeled.
Then from that, based
on these risk segments,
then using AI,
created a number of customized messages.
And when I say a number,
I mean thousands of customized messages,
SMS messages, email messages,
messages that are targeted
to those different audience segments.
And again, using AI, specifically LLMs,
we're able to basically run simulations,
again, hundreds of
thousands of simulations
using these messages
against these audience segments.
And they could look at
things like click rates
or open rates,
like, model these in simulation
rather than testing
these on actual people.
The power of the cloud here
is that you can run these simulations
at massive, massive scale in
very short periods of time
at extreme low cost.
And with it, ultimately
what you get out of it
are the perfect message for each channel,
like SMS or email,
for each audience segment.
The ones that that person
is going to open and click
and is going to resonate with the best.
To Glenn's point,
you want that kind of Amazon experience.
You want the company to know you.
This is that more personalized experience.
And then I'll turn it back over to Glenn
for what that actually
looked like in practice.
- Thanks.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so what I'm gonna show you now,
we started with an ad,
again, hyper personal,
now we're talking about
member communications
and this is when we,
oh, you can't hear me?
Yeah. Okay.
High five? Bad?
Okay.
That was a real-time NPS score.
You know, I showed you the ad
and here we are talking about retention
and member communications.
On the left is information we sent out
starting from July actually,
July all the way through September,
to let people know,
I would draw your attention
to the chart on the bottom,
this is personalized to each household,
what is this EPTC thing, right?
We know that people don't
need to know those acronyms,
but we wanted to help
people to understand,
in the case of this example,
you're getting a total of $500 worth
of subsidy or assistance
between these two
different sources of help
and this is set to expire in December.
We started sending that out in July,
you know, pretty early on.
And in comparing notes with our colleagues
across the nation,
you know, we were all trying
to figure out what to do
to get people's attention
and to really start to plant that seed.
And then I would draw your
attention to the right,
which is enabled by what
Chris just described,
this email goes longer and longer,
but it's basically very tailored
to each household, each segment,
and what they need to see
in terms of even their choices
of switching from different metal tiers,
gold, platinum, bronze, so on,
or even looking at different plans.
That sounds pretty par for the course.
I don't expect you guys
to do the wave for me.
Maybe outside I can induce you to do that.
But I can tell you for Covered California
and for our peers across the nation,
this is big, right?
It's us really, again, leaning hard
into what is the customer experience
that today's modern
consumer expects from us,
but that, frankly, large
government organizations
often find hard to do, right?
It is hard to do for a lot of reasons,
but because of all the technology
and investment of time,
we're able to do that.
And what I would say is
that, am I doing this one?
Okay, okay, here we go.
- Sure, yeah, thanks.
Okay, so that was the outreach.
So now we've reached the people.
Now they might have interest,
they might have questions,
so they might call, you
know, they call back in.
And when they reach the contact center,
we wanted that personalized
experience to continue.
So in a similar manner as
for the outbound campaign,
now we're looking at providing
that customized experience
for the customer
as they're coming back in.
So a set of custom messages,
when a person calls in,
they're gonna basically be
connected to a contact center.
In this case, it's Amazon
Connect for Covered California.
When they connect to Amazon Connect,
using text-to-speech,
or basically, let me back up,
we're doing a dynamic lookup in Salesforce
to find that customer profile information
and find that audience segment
and that risk score that
they're basically assigned to
and then dynamically going into DynamoDB
to look up and find a customized message
for that audience, you know,
segment, for that person.
Then using text-to-speech
and Amazon Connect,
we're able to play that message.
So it's customized to them.
At some point, they're gonna
get transferred to an agent.
And when they get transferred to an agent,
the agent is also going to get played
a customized whisper message
letting them know who this customer is
and their potential risk.
So now that agent is going
to provide customized
or personalized, I should say, support
for that particular
caller when they call in.
In addition, the Deloitte team developed
a customer retention
workspace for the enrollers
so that they have,
like, a set of high-risk
or at-risk customers that
they can reach out to.
And the ability, once
they reach out to them,
to then re-score or
basically disposition them,
like, "Okay, we reached out, they renewed.
We reached out, they're switching plans.
We reached out, they declined."
So now gathering a lot of data,
and then that in turn fed
into dashboards at the end
that, you know, now they have
just a lot more information
about how effective that
these campaigns are.
So, again, you're receiving
customized messages.
Now when you're calling in,
you're getting customized messages,
and the agents that are supporting you
are supporting you with,
they know who you are and
how to support you best.
And the best part,
maybe the best slide in
this whole slide deck,
is the impact that this created.
- Thanks, Chris.
I tried to steal his slide
'cause if you spend
enough time with IT guys,
you wanna become one.
So I was trying to steal your slide.
But, you know, from a results perspective,
you know, what it really
ends up being about
is what does it do, right?
It's not personalization
for the sake of it.
It's not all this work just
because we think it's right
or we think it's gonna pay off.
And what we're sharing
here is on the top part,
these are, immediately
following the campaign,
literally the next day
after the campaign launched,
and again, this is multimodal,
so you have email, you have SMS,
you have other things going off,
we had 5x the phone calls
that we normally would on that day.
We had 125% more traffic to our website
and we had 40% increase in logins.
And we can deduce that
those people were looking
at the plans that we sent
that personalized information to, right?
That's just the first
day after this was sent.
And then when we look
at the first two weeks
after that campaign,
it's basically a 3x improvement
in terms of retention.
Again, the goal is retention, right?
So for people who
experience the personalized,
the aggregate effort of
being more segmented,
being more personalized,
we can see the payoff here.
And we're very hopeful
that in spite of the price
and affordability challenges,
this is what the approach
is that we're gonna do
because we're not gonna give up
on any single Californian, right?
The hard math of it is
that we can only do so much
and at some point there
will be, for some segments,
a very tough choice,
which I've said multiple times,
and we don't pretend that
any amount of personalization
is going to get them
over that tough choice
because it becomes Maslow's hierarchy,
it becomes prioritization
for them and their life.
But at the same time, who would
we be if we give up on this?
We're going to continue to do
everything we know how to do
and everything that you can
all in the audience help us do
to fight to keep people covered.
And if we can't get them covered,
to fight to help them understand
that we care about them,
they should pick up the phone
and we can walk through whatever options
they want to explore with us.
And so these results are,
you know, they're not
just sort of a vanity
set of numbers for us.
They're proof that we're
on the right path here
in terms of our approach.
I'm gonna do this slide
'cause I feel like I can.
No, I'm just kidding.
(all chuckle)
- Okay, so we'll talk,
I've already briefly talked
about how this works,
but we'll walk through it again.
So based on the risk scores
and the audience segments,
basically an encrypted
CSV file was developed
and built by the Deloitte team
and loaded into Salesforce.
So now Salesforce has a
mapping of the customers
to their risk or to
their audience segment.
When a customer calls
in to Amazon Connect,
right here in the middle,
there is a lookup that's
done through Lambda
back to Salesforce
to find out what is that
customer's risk score,
what is our audience segment?
And then from that, a lookup to DynamoDB
to get the specific message
that's going to be
played in Amazon Connect,
again, using the built in
text-to-speech function.
Correct me if I'm wrong,
English and Spanish, correct?
Yeah, okay, English and Spanish.
So that message is then played back
to the consumer while they're,
customer, sorry, while
they're waiting in queue.
At the same time, the
whisper message for the agent
is also being retrieved
and it will be ready
when the customer is
transferred to the agent.
There's a lot of other
services that were used
to build ultimately,
again, I mentioned R on Snowflake earlier,
to build the risk scores
and the audience segments.
A lot of analytics tools that were used,
visualization, like
Tableau, as shown here.
Lots and lots of things that went behind,
services that went into
this behind the scenes
to build the model,
but on a daily basis, on a per call basis,
Dynamo, Lambda, Salesforce,
Kinesis to stream out the
analytics data to Verint today.
All of these services are
used on every single call,
providing that personalized experience.
And what this does, this is
just the first phase, right?
So the data's gonna continue
to be analyzed and looked at,
and again, we've got the, I say we,
the team collectively analyzing the data
and this can be continually improved on.
So, you know, just really exciting stuff.
So what's next?
As we are looking out into 2026
and some enhancements
that can be made here,
one of the big items that
stands out is an integration,
a deeper integration with Salesforce.
And this is really going
to provide benefits
not only for the customers
of Covered California
by providing self-service,
like personalized
self-service when you call in.
Again, lookups can be
made back into Salesforce
and that personalized, like,
self-service information
could be provided back right in the IVR.
But also a lot of agent assistance.
So things like dynamically
providing answers to questions
to the agent, like, live
while the conversation is happening.
A summary of contacts when it's over.
So instead of spending 60
seconds or two minutes,
like, typing up a summary
of what just happened on that contact,
just use AI to provide a
summary of that contact
and move on to the next one.
That not only helps with
that particular call,
but the next call.
When that person calls again,
now you can you say, "Oh, I
see you talked to this person
and you talked about this," right?
It helps all along the way.
So, you know, just announced
this week at re:Invent
some of what that looks like here.
Salesforce contact center
with Amazon Connect.
An inbound call comes in in
the Salesforce interface.
An agent doesn't have to leave,
so they're not working
from multiple screens.
They can answer.
This is just a chat in this case,
but that customer's record is pulled up.
So now the agent has a view
of all of that customer's information,
previous contact information,
you know, everything about them.
As they start chatting,
this is not a Covered California example,
so if you need help with
generator installation,
that's what this is about.
But, you know, I need some
help installing a generator,
well, live while they're talking,
or in this case, it's chat,
but this works with voice as well,
Amazon Connect, through
Salesforce, is providing answers
to that customer's question
or to their inquiry live.
And as an agent now,
I don't have to, like,
"Let me put you on hold
and go look that information up."
That information is being
brought right to the agent live.
In this case, because it's a chat,
they could literally just
copy it and paste it in,
helping that customer.
We could provide sources to that.
So if you needed to dive deeper
or, you know, look up more
information, you could.
And down here, I kind of
cut it off on the screen,
but an agent could even just type in here
and just ask questions
if they wanted to ask deeper questions
about this particular topic.
But all of this now is
going to help answer
the customer's question faster
and ultimately, you know, just provide
a better customer experience
for customers of California.
So with that, I'll turn it over to Kevin.
- I think just a couple
of thoughts to close
and to take away.
One, we started this journey
looking for partners,
not for vendors,
but for human beings who had affinity
for those three care-abouts I
talked about earlier, right?
Our obsessions, our mission.
Affordable, high-quality
healthcare is a right
for every resident of
the state of California.
That second one about the consumer journey
and trying to remove impedance
or friction from that journey
so that consumers can get
from point A to point Z fast,
speedy, with no issues,
and feel confident that
they have the right solution
at the end of that journey.
And obviously information
security and privacy.
So those three care-abouts,
we have two fantastic partners in Deloitte
as our system integrator
and AWS as our infrastructure provider.
These folks, these human
beings have the same affinity
for our mission that we do, right?
Glenn and I are, we're employees
of the state of California.
And so we're here
because we wanted to
do this mission thing.
We have two partners who are also here
and we treat them like they're
our employees as well, right?
We are all colleagues.
I think the second thing is
we spent a lot of time today
talking about data and AI and ML
and it's really the transition
or translation of data into insight
that AI and ML gives us,
that insight that actually
drives action, right?
The insight that drives action,
like, "Hey, 30% of your people are leaving
and never coming back.
What are you gonna do about it?"
The insight that drives action of,
"Hey, let's create a custom message
and a custom outreach campaign
that will get every single human being
to think I am thinking about
you in this transaction,
I'm thinking about your family
and what your needs are,
and I'm giving you a custom plan
and I'm explaining it in a language
and in a method that you can understand
and take action on too."
So it's that transformation of data
into insight that drives action,
which is really at the heart
of the two use cases that we provided.
Anything else to add, Glenn?
- We're just excited to
keep this going forward
and this is just the beginning
and we've done this collectively
in a very short period of time.
So we're excited to keep charging ahead.
- Yeah, great.
Thank you for your time this afternoon.
We enjoyed telling you our story.
And we'll be at the back of
the room if you have questions.
- Thank you, everyone.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)